well we begin with breaking news out of
Libya the UN recognized government says
it will accept an offer of military
supports from Turkey the Tripoli base
administration is fighting an offensive
by warlord Khalifa Haftar whose forces
are trying to capture a capital schools
in the southern turistic of Abu Salim
and Tripoli have now been suspended the
municipality says it's because of
sporadic fighting and shelling by half
those forces now we have three reporters
in three countries crucial to their
story step vasila standing by in Moscow
Mohammad addo is in Istanbul but first
let's go to Mahmoud Abdul Wahid in
Tripoli Mahmoud waterview was the latest
on these developments what what he tell
us
well hala
this meeting is crucial by the GNA the
government of national Accord which met
with military commanders belonging to
the volcana of Rath operation the
counter military offensive to defend the
capital tripoli against Hathor's forces
and the government says it now being
entitled to demand military assistance
from Turkey that is by virtue of the
military and security agreement or
memmer marine memorandum of
understanding that was sealed between
the UN recognized Libyan Prime Minister
Fayyad Suraj and the Turkish president
Rajab type of the one the last month now
government sources say that not only
Turkey is going to be demanded to send
the weapons to the GNA but also they
have they have asked three other
countries the United States Britain and
Italy - for also for military assistance
and when we ask the government sources
why especially these three countries
they said that for two main reasons
first of all to guarantee extra
assistance military assistance of the
three countries agreed to send military
and logistical support to the GNA
and second to guarantee that the three
countries will not object on the Turkish
military assistance to to the GNA the
government of national Accord also this
step had as you know that is a kind of
reaction to the Russian as the GNA calls
it Russian intervention in Libya
especially supporting door law relief
ahead as you know about a thousand
Russian military individuals or
mercenaries are fighting for the world
horrific after trying to support or help
his forces get into the capital's city
center that's according to government
officials they say that about a thousand
Russian mercenaries are now fighting for
the warlord cliff after that's along
with other African mercenaries from Chad
and from Sudan also supporting the road
Khalifa Haftar when we asked at the
government officials why they have now
decided to put this Agreement the
military agreement with Turkey in place
they say that half the forces have been
supporting by several regional powers
including Egypt the United Arab Emirates
and Jordan they say that half those
forces have been receiving advanced
weapons from the United Arab Emirates
for the past four years including
fighter jets and advancing drones and
also the battles including the battle to
control Tripoli by hostile forces have
been run by Russian Emirati
and Egyptian military experts that's
again according to the GNA the
government of national Accord so it is
expected that the coming few weeks will
weten its escalation in southern Tripoli
and meanwhile the fight or the war Halla
has been taken at a heavy toll on
civilians as you know that hundreds of
civilians have been killed or wounded by
random rockets or air strikes by half
there's fighter jets and about a hundred
hundred thirty thousand people 130,000
people have been displaced from their
homes because of the fighting and also
today schools in Abu Salim a densely
populated area
the city center has suspended work and
the schools because as they say of the
deteriorating situation around Muslim
neighborhood ok Mahmoud Abdul Ahad
bringing us the latest from Tripoli
thank you very much turkey of course a
big part of the story let's say close to
Mohammed AD oh he's lifers in Istanbul
Mohammed what have we been hearing aids
of Turkey this prince the Turkish
government at odds really with its
one-time ally Russia yes indeed and they
seem not to be reading from the same
hymn sheet when it comes to the
situation of Libya but it will be a
while before we see Turkish troops on
the ground in Libya because there is a
whole process involved right now that
military agreement between Tripoli and
Ankara is going through Parliament it
just passed and got the approval of the
Foreign Affairs Committee in Parliament
next Wednesday it's going for vote in
parliament there is a lot of opposition
to it but it's expected to sail through
and once that agreement between Tripoli
and Ankara is ratified by Parliament
everything will be hinged on a formal
request from the DNA in Tripoli that's
the Libyan government in Tripoli to ask
formally for the deployment of the
troops and then that has to go back to
Parliament for a vote and it's only
after Parliament gives its mandate or
not only troop numbers but also what the
work that they will be doing in Tripoli
that they would be allowed to be
deployed ok Mohamed adore live for as
there in Istanbul thank you well
russia's President Vladimir Putin has
spoken about the conflicts in Libya
during his yearly wide-ranging media
conference so let's go live to step
fasten who's a normal school for us and
stepped it's the Russian president's
address the situation
it's all during that that lengthy press
conference it was lengthy indeed there
was more than four hours
President Putin addressed the questions
of journalists and there was this one
question by a Turkish journalist who
asked him directly is Russia backing
half-strands troops and he said do you
believe everything Western media are
reporting and he said no we are
basically in touch with both sides from
touch with the government forces and
with after he's been on the phone with
Emmanuel McCoy and also with Angela
Merkel to discuss the situation in Libya
and in the next coming days a delegation
from Turkey will arrive here in Moscow
and he hopes that all these
conversations are not specifically this
dialogue with the Turkish delegation
could lead to some kind of peaceful
settlement or at least the start of a
dialogue to find a solution to the
ongoing violence in Libya that's
basically what he said during the
presser but of course we have to
remember that there are hundreds and
maybe a thousand mercenaries mercenaries
fighting on the side of half the has
been has been said earlier and of course
there's a lot of questions about what
are the exact objectives there are of
course speculations about the business
side of the the conflict the oil
resources that Libya has but also it
shows that that Russia like it has been
doing in Syria always likes to support
the strongman it has been able to keep
Assad in power and it's also believed
that after is also seen by Russia as
this kind of strongman that that Russia
can do business with
stepheson their life rests in Moscow
thank you